got the pressure to do a book which i
felt i wasn't ready to do you weren't
ready to divulge were you not at all so
i wrote just a geek when i was like 26
or 27.
and wow so this follow-up's 20 something
years later it's 18 and a half years
later
wow and
i am so grateful to my editor david
pomerico at morrow because david
uh we submitted a manuscript my agent
and i submitted a manuscript that i had
written for a fictional
semi-autobiographical fictional story
and um i knew
that this book needed something i didn't
know what it was i knew that it wasn't
quite complete and i was like if i can
find an editor who wants to work on this
together
this is gonna be a cool story i know it
and nobody really wanted to do that but
david was like i really liked just a
geek and i recently reread it and i've
re and i've been listening to you now
and you're such a different person
just look at it and see if you would
want to go back and annotate it and
revisit it
and like
finish
that story which was started and left
incomplete 18 years ago did you feel
like it was incomplete is that somebody
or did you hearing that from someone i
was like oh my god you're right i didn't
know that it was incomplete wow until i
sat down to do it so i sat down and i
started annotating it right right and
immediately i'm like oh my god dude you
make a stupid homophobic joke because
it's like a lazy high school joke right
and uh i had to annotate that and
immediately talk about like why that is
not okay now it wasn't okay then why
younger me thought it was taking
responsibility and why it's like really
gross and offensive right right then i
get into like oh my god i just turned
like oh i just took this this woman
who's like doing her job and i made her
a punch line because it makes me the
hero of the story and i was like that's
not okay either and it's lazy writing
it's bad writing so i on annotated that
then i got to a place where i and i
don't remember specifically what it was
but i got to a place where i i read what
was in the original just a geek and i
got to the end of like that paragraph or
that chapter or whatever
and i knew
all of this was happening because i
desperately wanted my dad to notice me
and i need to talk about that and i
started writing about that
and then i started writing about
um
all the other things i held back
and
i kind of revisited all of this stuff
and there's moments in that book
things that were massively consequential
at the time that they happened like you
know kind of almost getting a job that
that i had completely forgotten about
uh auditions that were like i worked so
hard to prep the auditions and then the
auditions were awful like you know you
work really hard i don't i don't know
how long it's been since you had to
audition but like do you remember you
work really hard to prep a role you feel
good about it they're like there's six
scenes you prep all of them you go in
they don't care that you're there and
you start and they go oh we're only
doing the first scene why the [ __ ] did i
prep six scenes if we're only doing the
first scene i'm like look man just tell
me the truth we've cast this yesterday
and we didn't want to cancel the session
you know like cool i'm here like this is
what i look like this is what i sound
like uh maybe you keep me in mind for
something else but don't put me through
this yeah right that happens a lot yep
so and i was just like
i hate this
and i hate that i had to act my whole
life
like it's awesome you know like well you
just got to keep on going and i was like
no it's [ __ ] and it sucks and i hate
it and i started telling that part of
the story
and then i just in the process of doing
all of this
i was simultaneously
doing a lot of
uh therapy and a lot of academic
research into childhood trauma and how
it affects the developing childhood
brain and i began to very clearly see
what a traumatic childhood i really had